Es ist soweit künstliche intelligenz ki
besiegt den menschen und das in immer mehr bereichen ist ist schon ein wenig beängstigend vielen mast und stephen hawking hatten ja
vorausgesagt dass uns ki
extrem gefährlich werden kann wo uns
bereits heute überlegen ist jetzt in klicks und science fiction herzlich willkommen und vielen dank für den themenvorschlag über whatsapp
Und jetzt erstmal eine kleine sensation vor zehn jahren ende september 2008 haben wirklich zum gestartet und heute
starten wir wieder
clixoom auf englisch ab sofort gibt es einen zweiten kanal mit den besten und
aktuellen science fiction videos auf englisch wer also lieber englische videos sieht oder englisch lernen will
das geht ab sofort auf klicks um
science-fiction auf englisch ihr gelangt hier über die infoguard zum kanal das erste video ist bereits veröffentlicht und heute abend um 18 uhr
kommt ein video dass es noch nicht auf dem deutschen kanal gibt also direkt abonnieren um nichts mehr zu verpassen erst kürzlich im juli
2018 hat google verkündet dass die von dem unternehmen entwickelte künstliche
intelligenz menschliche spieler in einem ego shooter game besiegt und das sehr
zuverlässig doch das ist nicht der einzige bereich unseres lebens in dem neuronale netze uns menschen mittlerweile
überlegen sind künstliche intelligenz zum beispiel die ein falsches
von einem echten lächeln unterscheiden kann oder aber eine ki die uns menschen demnächst von allen möglichen krankheiten height
100 für die küken und dabei teamplayer sein google sky heißt vor gewinn
ftd und bringt uns in sachen gaming echt zum staunen die software kann mit menschen aber auch mit anderen maschinen
zusammenarbeiten und sich auf bestimmte spielweisen einstellen und eben auch gewinnen konkret geht es um den modus capture the flag
des shooter games quake 3 arena
bei dem die fahne des gegners zur eigenen basis gebracht werden muss diesen erfolg von
fd dario hat jetzt das entwicklerteam verkündet etwa
450.000 simulierten partien hat die ki gespielt und so dazugelernt stichwort die learning
sowohl was das teamwork als auch die spielmechanik angeht und das game ist
60 nur ein wenig abgeändert vom original die grafik ist etwas simpler gestaltet und statt echten modellen gibt es beispielsweise
kugeln dann ist die ki in einem turnier gegen 40 spieler angetreten in einem team aus ausschließlich
maschinellen spielern hat sie jedes spiel gegen menschen gewonnen
jedes spiel
und auch ihre pfote gegen ein gemischtes team also aus mensch und maschine war mit 95
prozent mehr als beachtlich überrascht waren die entwickler von ft damit
dass sie selbst taktiken angewandt hatte die auch echte gamer also menschen nutzen wie beispielsweise
ablenkungsmanöver oder das verteidigen der eigenen basis andere forschungsteams sind gerade dabei
computern das pokern beizubringen und tatsächlich sind einige programme auch schon in der lage zu bleiben zwei zu null für die ki
menschliche emotionen erkennen egal ob überraschung trauer ekel wut oder freude all diese
gefühlsregungen kann dass die learning system der amerikanischen firma
effektiver korrekt zuordnen und deuten dazu hatten ihm seine entwickler und
entwicklerinnen videos von menschen in 75 ländern vorgespielt die genau diese emotionen zeigen und sich weltweit gleich in den gesichtern spiegeln egal
woher die menschen kommen wie alt sie sind oder welches geschlecht sie haben die so entwickelte kai ist mittlerweile schneller und auch genauer als die
meisten menschen sie kann sogar ein echtes von einem falschen lächeln unterscheiden das talent der ki soll demnächst übrigens auch im
straßenverkehr eingesetzt werden das system hat dann die aufgabe
den autofahrer oder die autofahrerin vor der fahrt abzuchecken ob das emotionale gleichgewicht
überhaupt zum autofahren geeignet ist denn wer wütend oder aufregt ist wird schneller zum risiko im straßenverkehr
die mimik des fahrers oder der fahrerin soll über eine kamera analysiert
werden auch wenn sie oder er zu viel getrunken hat vor freude aus dem häuschen ist oder aber immer wieder das
smartphone am steuer benutzt dann wird das von der ki
offengelegt 3 zu 0 für die caps spielen und krankheiten
diagnostizieren darüber haben wir hier ja schon öfter berichtet die blondine kann ärzteteams sehr effektiv unterstützen beispielsweise
können die algorithmen lernen gesunde zellen von krebszellen zu unterscheiden
indem sie nach verdächtigen merkmalen suchen zudem kann die aber auch nach wirkstoffen und medikamenten cocktail suchen
die individuell für jeden patienten und jede patientin am passendsten sind dazu ein paar konkrete
beispiele google möchte beispielsweise mit hilfe von software depressionen heilen und herzinfarkte mit hilfe künstlicher nano-partikel
voraussagen das projekt heißt hannover die idee dahinter computer sollen sich zunächst einmal das komplette medizinische wissen aneignen heißt also
studien lesen und verstehen
millionen von artikeln sind verfügbar und täglich kommen neue erkenntnisse hinzu wie soll da ein mensch mit kommen das ist einfach
unmöglich aber kein großes problem für maschinen sie sollen ärzteteams in zukunft dann dabei unterstützen personalisierte
behandlungsmethoden zu finden ibm hat eine ki entwickelt die die dna sequenzierung eines gehirntumors schneller und zuverlässiger
analysiert hat als das gesamte team der
menschlichen experten und expertinnen
40 für die
juristische klauseln analysieren bei der studie der plattform logix ging es um die analyse der geheimhaltung verträge großer
25 top anwälte traten gegen den algorithmus an und die ki
gewann haushoch das ziel war es fünf verträge innerhalb von vier stunden zu analysieren und 30 rechtliche probleme zu identifizieren
die ki hat für fünf verträge nur rund 25 sekunden gebraucht die anwälte
benötigten durchschnittlich 92 minuten zudem war die arbeit die ihn noch
sorgfältiger als sie der menschlichen anwälte ihre genauigkeit lag bei 94 prozent die ihrer menschlichen konkurrenz bei 85 prozent
bei einem vertrag kamen der beste der anwälte auf 97 aber auch hier war die kab st sie erlangte eine
hundertprozentige genauigkeit
15 neu für die wartung von maschinen ja den letzten punkt den gibt es im duell mensch gegen künstliche
intelligenz bei der wartung von maschinen auch hier geht es um die analyse einer gigantischen datenflut die
neuronale netze deutlich schneller und zuverlässiger analysieren können als wir menschen
windturbinen beispielsweise produzieren pro tag hunderte gigabyte daten und die ki lernt diese zu interpretieren
also bei windrädern ist das der fall die gehen ja immer wieder kaputt und die ständig zu analysieren das kann
am besten gibt es nämlich eine ungewöhnliche schwingung oder muss in der nächsten zeit eine wartung durchgeführt werden so können mögliche
beschädigungen schon wochen vorausgesehen werden und es kommt zu weniger oder im besten fall
sogar keinem ausfall der turbinen mehr eine leistung die menschen einfach nicht erbringen können
und jetzt brauche ich eure unterstützung lasst uns den englischen kanal so richtig pushen kriegt also hier drauf
abonniert live kommentiert und haut ordentlich auf die
genau auf die glocke erzählt euren englischsprachigen science freundin von uns
austauschschülern oder allen die ihr englisches vokabular ein bisschen verbessern wollen teilt das ganze bis der arzt kommt und wir sehen uns um 18 uhr
dort auf dem kanal für ein brandneues video dass es im deutschen noch nicht gab und
hier geht es weiter mit dem ersten englischen video also unbedingt drauf klicken das zeigen feel like stay tuned
csu